tquel ça à 50 km au nord-est de tunis
semble figée dans le temps
loin de l'agitation de la capitale dans
cette ville à la fois cotchery agricole
la recrudescence des cas positifs au
comique 19 est venue perturber le
quotidien des agriculteurs notamment le
maire un édile qui n'a pas hésité à
monter au créneau pour dénoncer
l'inaction du gouvernement et
l'appréciation à la baisse que ce
dernier a fait de la situation sanitaire
de sa commune ici attaqué le ca nous
sommes la plus grande commune du
gouvernorat de nabeul avec 25000
habitants
la situation ici est catastrophique les
chiffres que nous annoncent nos médecins
locaux sont loin d'être ceux publiés par
l' agence régionale de santé qui chaque
jour annonce des chiffres différents
hier 0 aujourd'hui 1 avant-hier 8
les chiffres que nous avons ici dépasse
les 2000 cas positifs depuis quelques
semaines ce virus est en train de se
propager très vite
nous voulons connaître la cause et
surtout savoir pourquoi la rs publie des
chiffres erronés
désemparé il a l'impression de mener ce
combat seul face à une population peu
consciente du danger des forces de
l'ordre aux abonnés absents et un
gouvernement qui semble ne pas vouloir
prendre ses responsabilités nous tentons
au maximum de sensibiliser la population
sur le port du masque d'éviter les
rassemblements notamment dans les cafés
mais cette mission ne peut pas être
menée par le maire seul chacun doit
prendre ses responsabilités à commencer
par les autorités la police par exemple
pourrait punir ceux qui ne porte pas de
masque
tout le monde doit être responsable et
l' agence régionale de santé doit nous
communiquer les chiffres exacts pour que
nous puissions agir en conséquence et
prendre des mesures sévères et ferment
chaque jour il fait le point avec les
quatre médecins de la ville afin
d'évaluer la situation en temps réel
voici l'un des quatre cabinets médicaux
de la commune tous ouverts de 8h à 22h
car nous sommes dépourvus d'hôpitaux
dans le coin excusez une seconde s'il
vous plaît à l'eau
très bien j'arrive tout de suite je suis
désolé on vient de m'annoncer deux morts
supplémentaires
je dois me rendre à la mairie pour
signaler les actes de décès les annonces
de décès sont quasiment devenues
quotidiennes dans cette agglomération
agricole qui a l'impression d'avoir été
oubliés par tunis à seulement une heure
de route
malgré cette situation il faut continuer
de sauver des vies c'est la mission que
s'est confiée rihab bel haj salah l'un
des quatre généralistes de thé calza un
travail devenu pénible par manque de
moyens alors que son cabinet ne
désemplit pas en 1 seulement c'est une
situation catastrophique attaque elle ça
c'est une situation catastrophique
demandez moi pourquoi simplement cats à
quel saint nous avons beaucoup de cas
sous-estimer et les gens sont en train
de mourir les gens meurent tout
simplement pourquoi par défaut de moyens
non aller par défaut de moyens
les baisses rapides franchement je dis
les ppr manque de tests rapides de tests
pcr je suis à 45 cas par jour c'est
affreux si je dois me débrouiller tout
seul comme c'est le cas pour mes
collègues au moins aider nous ne nous
laissez pas comme ça donnez nous des
concentrateurs à 10 litres et nous nous
débrouillerons à qui on a des
concentrateurs a dit la mort est devenu
le quotidien de cette ville dont le
cimetière est devenu plus fréquentés
qu'à l'accoutumée au grand dam du maire
nous sommes ici au cimetière de takelsa
où nous sommes rendus aujourd'hui
enterré des gens tous les jours à cause
de ce qu vide hier les autorités
parlaient d'un cas positif alors que le
même jour
nous avons eu deux décès des chiffres
erronés une ville sinistrée
le cas de tekel ça est loin d'être une
exception dans un pays où médecins
associations et citoyens tire la
sonnette d'alarmé face à un système de
santé à l'agonie et un gouvernement qui
semble avoir perdu le contrôle de la
situation
comme walid amiri de plus en plus de
mères n'hésitent plus à monter au
créneau pour que le pouvoir tunisien
prenne enfin ses responsabilités